every resort town in the US has a candy
store but one store in his mo Beach
California goes beyond the usual taffy
and caramel apples if hot licks has its
way Americans will be snacking on
everything from caterpillars and
cockroaches to mealworm covered apples
Larry Peterman is a candy man on a
mission for more than a decade he's been
promoting a valuable food source that
most Americans find revolting in a land
of plenty people resist Larry knows why
from an early age parents teach children
to avoid insects in our culture from the
time that we're really small we're
taught to avoid insects they might bite
you like a mosquito I've got a good
that's got a good cricket in it but kids
aren't the only ones munching on bugs
around the world more than 1,400 insect
species show up on menus insect dating
or entomophagy is part of healthy diets
in Asia Africa Australia and Latin
America this trend is anything but new
archaeologists have found evidence of it
dating to the earliest humans advocates
of insect eating like to note that it's
environmentally sound producing a pound
of caterpillar takes a tenth of the
resources needed to produce a pound of
beef
and insects brim with vitamins and
minerals but despite all the benefits
most Americans can't stomach bugs
welcome welcome welcome ever seen unlike
Larry Peterman who celebrates them at
his dinner party gentlemen are the
evening begins with Larry's version of
the classic shrimp cocktail we're just
finished preparing a cricket cocktail
it's a lot like a shrimp cocktail holy
instead of shrimp we use crickets okay
folks here's the first course now enjoy
it's amazing while you're enjoying this
I'm going down and get your next course
the main course is a stir fry a special
garnish here we go dinner is served
you ever get ready okay go three go
several courses later Larry presents his
piece de resistance here it is both what
you've been waiting for now go there
anybody dive it in till everyone to the
curb please we call them a pismo surfer
what it is is a banana with whipped
cream and a really good cockroach honor
you don't have to eat the wings you
don't have to eat the head I did unless
you want to you know oh you know where
this car has just been we could do
another one next week if you like Larry
predicts he'll eventually win people
over as we become more and more insect
food oriented our tastes go Jade and so
I see a niche for somebody that does
gourmet insects
could have some snob appeal like people
taste wines open listen to this bug is
good